waitwait tell the story tell the story
is if third party
okay you're not Bryan Callen yeah but
I'm a guy the bar and I'm talking about
Bryan Callen and you tell me how he died
okay
yeah so this is the part that matters to
me okay yeah man I did I love the
Goldbergs Bryan columns like my favorite
actor dude I used to love fighting the
kid his stand-up whatever happened to
Bryan Callen friend of mine oh you knew
Brian died yeah
I wasn't privy to the video unto the to
the auditorium wow we went out you saw
the video I saw the video well boy how
did he die well they were in India and
he was helping the local populace there
and he was very much into women's rights
and just human rights I don't know that
but it's a real champion of the people
and he gave and gave and gave and they
were they were out digging a well for
this wonderful village and he did it by
hand I don't know if you ever saw his
back the road man he sounds like he was
really strong he could do it yeah he can
take it well on an afternoon
I don't know anybody was an actor but he
was a really out quite an athlete and
love really moved him oh yeah I was a
fan of his too how did he die there was
he was with a group of women there was
this charity where they had all of the
Miss America runner ups with him and
some of the girls especially who had
been exposed for doing some nefarious
new stuff that Miss America didn't want
anyway he was there and he was keeps a
natural leader and he had taken them on
a fact-finding mission yeah they were
help they were helping him and providing
inspiration for the world digging and
stuff and but how did he die so he was
he used to dig in a loincloth and he
yeah and he he and that was fashioned
for him by one of the one of the local
and very beautiful young ladies and he a
tiger Shere Khan sure conquer come
that's a Hindu for tiger
showed up and came out a woman and I
know Brian mustard he he did not like
when wild animals [ __ ] with women he
didn't like when any he didn't like with
directors or breathe he was at shanty
anyone wild enough women's rights and
human rights I don't know if I said that
before that guy gave till it hurts and
he said not on my watch [ __ ] and he doe
did he have mostly fast twitch muscles
so it was amazing how fast he dope
and it was funny to see in midair
because they slowed the camera down the
line the tiger recognized in midair you
could see his expression change and
recognize it was gonna have its hands
full and recognized that this dude when
he pulled his knife from his loincloth
and he went not on my watch [ __ ] and he
he jumped sort of into the maw of the
tiger and he drove his knife and he
didn't want to hurt the tiger and this
great [ __ ] guy beautiful about him
you could see him he was about to plunge
the knife and he went no and he dropped
the knife he put the tiger into his
guard and he brought the tiger in and he
said I love you to the girl into the
tiger and the tiger got him by the neck
and he died smiling if and the tiger
surprisingly let go of him and walked
back into the bush and this is so
[ __ ] crazy but it bowed to him about
yeah it's this is we're together you
would know this but it put its pause and
it just kind of put its nose to the
ground and went and it screamed and I
hollered and I heard this story I heard
that that some say and this is folklore
yeah that Brian became that time this is
so [ __ ] weird cuz they couldn't find
his body was it a tiger loincloth it was
he was wearing a tiger one with someone
please please make that artwork of Brian
flying through the air grabbing a tiger
who's flying in the air with one
under armed with a knife kind of
dropping it but the Tigers recognizing
it please please please I will pay to
make those shirts and I will give them
away I will give away a hundred shirts
if someone writes that I'm known in
India and degree and I think you need to
just transcribe all that and there's
your next pitch for Netflix right there
he did this is it just came out with a
great story
that's a hot set over there with this no
Bert was strangled by an anaconda in a
zoo watched him breathe by a funnel
spider and and died screaming with a
very small and all right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]